My life completely changed with one tweet.
This was back in 2015
when Twitter was mostly a place
we went to see what Kanye was mad about.
But then I saw it.
A tweet by a scientist I deeply admire,
Dr. Carolyn Porco.
Wait, I thought nuclear energy was bad.
Yet here is a scientist
and a TED speaker
making it sound good.
It sent me on a journey,
I spent years reading papers,
talking to scientists,
and I always asked them the same question:
What do you think about nuclear power?
Their responses were shockingly similar.
It's good.
We need it.
People hate it.
In the last seven years,
I've seen climate change go
from being a scary thing of the future
to being a scary thing of the present.
My wake-up call came after seeing
the fires ravage the world in California,
in Australia
and in my home country of Brazil.
I decided I wanted to turn
my growing sense of anger and despair
into something helpful and productive.
So I had an unusual idea:
I should be a nuclear energy influencer.
I wanted to make nuclear energy cool.
Inspired by internet culture,
I created a digital version of me
and called her Isodope.
(Laughter)
She's sassy,
a little weird,
but she always tells the truth.
And here, you can see her in action.
(Video) Hey, guys, a lot of you
asked about my make-up routine.
The most important thing
is to wash your face really well,
because we want those pores as clean
as we want our electricity.
And the best way to get that
is to use this cleanser called --
stop shutting down nuclear plants,
for Christ's sake.
It's carbon-free, emission-free,
pollution-free electricity.
Then I use this plant-based
serum called --
when a nuclear plant is shut down,
it is replaced by fossil fuels.
That's bad.
(Applause and cheers)
Isodope is like a dealer of good memes.
When I say meme, you probably think
of something like this.
(Laughter)
What I mean by it is a fixed belief
or idea, good or bad,
that spreads from person to person
and defines how we see the world.
For example,
people should have equal rights.
Birds aren't real.
It's a thing.
(Laughter)
Nuclear energy is bad.
When it comes to nuclear power,
the world has been sold a bad meme.
An outdated one.
Let's go back in time.
It all started with the anti-nuclear
movement of the 1970s.
The movement was driven in large part
by an understandable fear
of nuclear weapons.
And I get it.
It must have been terrifying
to grow up in the '50s and '60s
fearing a nuclear attack.
But here's the problem.
Their logic was: nuclear bombs are bad,
therefore nuclear energy is bad.
Which, if you think about it,
is like saying: the electric chair is bad,
therefore electricity is bad.
The case against nuclear power
was never based on science,
but the anti-nuclear meme was very catchy.
In the decades that followed,
aspiring engineers didn't choose
nuclear engineering.
Politicians got points
for closing nuclear plants,
even though it always led
to higher carbon emissions.
The meme even snuck into people's homes,
every Sunday night at eight,
without them knowing.
(Laughter)
I wish Homer had worked at a coal plant.
In the last 10 years,
we have spent trillions
of dollars on renewables,
yet we only get eight percent
of our electricity from wind and solar.
Now, don't get me wrong,
I love renewables,
but to me, it's clear that we need more.
We need a source of energy that's clean
and works 24/7 to complement them.
And it's been sitting right
in front of us this whole time,
but we have ignored it
because we're too blinded by the meme.
Now most people today
aren't exactly anti-nuclear
as much as they’re “meh.”
Not passionately against it,
but they've heard of Chernobyl.
They've seen images
of leaking green barrels.
They have a vague feeling it's bad.
And remember, that's where I used to be.
Until I saw this chart.
The only thing you need
to take away from this chart
is that nuclear power
has the lowest life cycle emissions
of all energy sources,
producing only three tons of CO2
per gigawatt hour of electricity.
And I could keep talking like this
all day long, but let's be real,
this is not changing minds
on social media.
So I do things a little bit differently.
(Video) The reality is that nuclear is one
of the safest forms of energy.
The problem is that nuclear
accidents are dramatic.
While fossil fuel damage is boring.
I'm literally falling asleep
talking about it.
Recent studies say that 8.7 million people
die from burning them every year.
This would be like having
5.8 Chernobyls a day.
I'm just a humble influencer,
but I think this means
fossil fuels are worse.
(Laughter)
(Applause)
Most people have a feeling
airplanes are more dangerous than cars
because when a plane crashes,
it makes the headlines.
It's memorable.
Of course, we know the opposite is true.
Planes are significantly safer than cars,
just like nuclear power
is significantly safer than fossil fuels.
In this next video, Isodope
will address the idea
that we don't know
what to do with nuclear waste.
(Video) I'm sure you don't know
what to do with it,
but there are people who spent
decades studying this issue.
They're called scientists.
Finland is almost done building
the world's first nuclear
waste repository.
They're storing it deep underground
in geologically stable locations.
Sweden is about to do the same.
I know you're worried about what may
happen 19,000 years from now, but ...
(Loud buzzing)
Again, just a humble influencer,
but we might not make it that far
if we keep burning fossil fuels.
(Applause)
By the way, most think nuclear
energy waste looks like this.
It actually looks like this.
Fully contained in concrete casks
that are so good at blocking radiation
I might do a photo shoot there.
Now, a more modern objection
to nuclear power
is that it's too slow.
It takes too long to build.
Well, I'm sure Isodope has something
to say about that.
(Video) (Isodope claps)
Finally, an argument
that isn't older than me.
Unfortunately, it still sucks.
In the '70s, France built
45 reactors in 15 years.
More recently, Japan, China and Korea
have built reactors in six years or less.
So this means BTS is blow-drying
their hair with clean energy.
Even if it takes 10 years to build one,
nuclear power plants can make clean
and reliable electricity
for at least 80 years.
This --
(Applause)
This idea that it takes too long
to build plants is confusing,
considering we're going
to need energy forever.
You know, the best time
to build nuclear plants
was 10 years ago.
The next best time is today.
Now we’ve finally arrived at the most
fashionable objection at the moment:
nuclear power is too expensive.
I'm going to take that one.
A little weird to say something
is too expensive
to save the future of our species,
but I get it, cost matters.
Here's the thing.
We know how to make clean energy cheaper.
It's not rocket science.
You build the same thing
over and over and over.
Solar, 10 years ago, was also
considered "too expensive,"
but we decided it was cool
and invested in it.
Like magic, the costs
have dropped by 90 percent.
One way to make nuclear cheaper
is with small modular reactors like these.
China just finished building
their own version.
Poland will use a similar technology
to convert their aging coal plants
into nuclear plants.
They'll use the same building,
the same transmission lines,
even retrain the same workers.
But now making clean energy
instead of buying dirty fuels
from dictators.
Which leads me to a crazy idea.
What if instead of viewing
nuclear power as destructive,
we view it as a force
for energy independence
and even peace.
What if this technology offers
our best hope for the future?
A future where wars aren't funded
by our addiction to fossil fuels.
A future where energy is clean.
A future where electricity
finally makes its way
to the 700 million people on Earth
who still don't have access to it.
The idea that nuclear power is bad
is costing us that future.
And it's time to let go of it.
I'm not asking you to build a reactor.
I'm not asking you to rewrite
"The Simpsons."
(Laughter)
I'm not even asking you to sign
a petition on Change.org.
All I'm asking you is to please,
join me in spreading the meme.
Nuclear energy is cool.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)